I threatened in a well-known gated
community in the southwest Valley people
who frequent the area say trash and the
water levels have made it impossible for
some of its fish and turtles to stay
alive 8 news now reporter Madison
Kimbrough has our story tonight
the guard gated community of Rhodes
ranch offers several amenities to its
residents but as you're about to see one
of their ponds on their Golf Course is
just about dried up and with it are dead
koi fish left floating behind you would
think that people are paying association
fee in the community here at Rose
Mansion definitely do a better job and
definitely not allow this to happen as
far as allowing all these Turtles and
fish to die Noel casemiro was an avid
golfer here at the Rhodes ranch golf
course but recently his attention has
shifted elsewhere as he couldn't help
but notice this depleting water levels
in the pond nearby with its Wildlife
struggling to survive at one point the
whole area was filled with water but
hasn't been in the past two months as
casemiro I came in and talked to those
guys in NASA the guys at the golf course
and say there's something to be done
with this and said that they're trying
to fix the other water pump and that's
the best they can do and just wait until
it gets done
um fast forward three three weeks later
and here we are casimiro posting on
social media about this as several
people in the community responding in
dislike all they had to do is put the
you know get a net put the fish in a
bucket and the turtles and just walk it
over there and they couldn't even do
that currently this was the only pod we
saw like this but many of the others
while they still had water had tons of
trash in them with its Wildlife having
to swim around it I've been coming here
for a long time also with my kids
feeding the dogs feeding the fishes and
it's just sad to see the water levels go
and then seeing all the turtles and and
the fish that were in here just drying
up dying and while we were at the golf
course we tried to get answers from a
manager on site but unfortunately no one
was available reporting from the
southwest Valley Madison Kimbrough eight
news now